so what is the process of rewiring that
like when you go to the ashram
and you start living as a monk what is
the teaching
like and what is what is the day-to-day
existence where you start to
um you know intuit these teachings and
put them into practice well there's a
there's a lot
to share i'm working a book right now
that extracted
six very powerful principles that i
taught from the teachings
um and uh the first one is and these are
based on the teachings of caitanya
mahaprabhu
um who was a great uh
considered by some as a child prodigy
because he was a child prodigy
um in sanskrit some other people that
knew more intimately
thought of he was a mystic because he
did he performed so many mystical things
christ-like mysticism and then but his
intimate followers who are great
gurus in their own right they considered
him an avatar so his teachings were very
simple
and one of him is very basic and it's a
great take away
if you want to take away anything from
today you take this away
stop criticizing other people
like that the the sound coming out of
your mouth
can be toxic and that was a powerful
thing
stop criticizing i realized i'm living
with so much criticism
in my mind that doesn't mean we should
throw discernment out we need
discernment
but the condemning language that happens
on a regular basis from finding fault
with other people
and how you would do things so much
better
if you were doing them cut it out stop
letting that pour out of your mouth that
was that's a big one
um if you want i'll just run through
these yeah let's do it now this is great
that's one thing first of all when did
this guy live like
is same time columbus was showing up
here
right this person chaitanya mahaprabhu
uh was uh in bengal and traveled
throughout india
and basically he was it was a
renaissance of bhakti bhakti means
bhakti yoga means connecting to source
through love that's all the word really
means
and so a lot of the practices are
singing
our cooking our meditation
but everything is in an action like
you're acting in a loving way and
dealing with other people and so um
so yeah this is one of the teachings i
call the book is called the six pillars
of bhakti
and and so one is not criticizing the
second one is being tolerant whereas
criticism deals with
with other people another one is just
dealing with
life's situation and stop blaming the
world for your unhappiness
and this is very powerful it's
transformational even if you're a
materialist
this main teaching can transform your
life but if you want to really
experience like the higher echelons of
meditation
it's got to be there
criticism tolerance and this isn't a
huge one that number three and if
if you can add this one to your life it
will it's just such a game changer it's
um i take no offense
meaning i will not be offended on a
regular basis
and that's a very common thing sometimes
we could see somebody talking over there
and i get offended i think they're
talking about me so without provocation
i think
someone's got something against me
and sometimes we'll walk around uh
holding some resentment for a person who
didn't even mean anything
and that gets split in two things
because sometimes people don't mean
anything
but due to some proclivity that i have
that i don't trust the world
that i take an offense and i carry that
resentment around with me and it becomes
a burden
but sometimes people have hurt me
they've actually deliberately hurt me
but still that desire or that need to
forgive has to be there
because in in the in the bhakti culture
is nothing's actually
happening to me it's happening for me
that there's a benevolent
energy lifting us higher and higher and
higher
and we have to and we have to see that
everything
is for my edification for my
purification and sometimes even tragic
things
um and so there's a firm faith that
everything's happening for me and that
we shouldn't be
we shouldn't be heartless when it comes
to someone else's suffering
i should see okay he's having a hard
time we should feel like i have to reach
out to that person they're having a hard
time
but for my own situation i should feel
like you know
i'm going through a hard time and this
must be for my
benefit what is that benefit and i can
look at it
i can look at life like that so we don't
hold any resentment we don't criticize
we're tolerant next one we see the good
in others and we let them know it
find good and this is what we're talking
about instead of finding what
this person's doing so wrong what are
they doing right
why are they good this is such a
powerful practice in this day and age
because otherwise we're going to lock in
and we're just going to foster hate
with others and you're we're going to
have no commonality whatsoever what do
we have in common
what is right about this person and it's
such a great thing truthfully it's a
it's a it's a marriage saver it's a
relationship
saver you know what is good about this
person
and then sharing it with them telling
why i appreciate you
and that lack of appreciation can really
kill
can kill love quick i mean isn't that
what romance is is
full 100 appreciation for that person
right
and the the the piece the second piece
about
letting that person know is is crazy
powerful
right and it's something that most of us
don't do nearly enough of
i mean we might have a person that would
do anything for us
they would come anywhere at any time at
any moment
hey i need your help can you come here
yeah that person i never let them know
how much i appreciate them sometimes the
people that are the closest to us
we never share with them how much we
appreciate right and then you recounting
these these lessons i'm thinking this
should be
the terms and conditions on twitter like
what if you before you could log on to
twitter you had to read through
these sort of you know guidelines or you
know
got you know sort of guide posts for how
to behave or acquit yourself because
everything that you just shared is so
anathema to the way that we conduct
ourselves
in the kind of public conversations that
are happening on social media and we're
all seeing
you know the fractures the fishers that
are
are starting to expand in the fabric of
you know our society like we're no
longer able to
productively communicate in a healthy
way and it's because we've lost sight of
these very things that that allow us to
remember that we are that we are truly
one
and no one's happy they're all sad even
if they're righteous they're just like
sad in their righteousness
of their rightness um
so that anyway that's that's uh uh see
the good nothers let them know it
the appreciation is such a powerful it's
powerful in this world
and it's powerful in the spiritual realm
as well that's why i love this stuff
because it's real it's relevant it's
real it's not just like
when i die i'll go to heaven who cares i
don't know about heaven i don't know
anything about heaven i don't even know
if it's real
but i do know these are very very
practical in this life for my own
personal joy
my own personal integrity my
relationships
um you were saying like yeah people in
twitter should learn this
the reason why i sort of like extracted
these from the teachings because i was
taking groups
every year i take a group on pilgrimage
this year i'm going to nepal it's sort
of like
you would like it you just go to these
various like spiritual sites all over
the world special sites all over the
world so we go
this year we're going trekking through
april uh nepal in april
wow um and so half the time is trekking
and then holy places and nepal is like
an old part of
the indian kingdom one of the indian
kingdoms they preserved a lot of the
ancient hindu texts the buddhist tax
and it's got whatever 1300 himalayan
peaks so
wow i'm gonna do day hiking halfway when
are you doing that april come
wow you're great that's tempting um but
keep going and then and then we do it
and we do
india every year which is also great and
holy places but
you know you're bringing a bunch of
people to india
who've never been to a third world
country and we're traveling together
and they're not used to it and it's a
little shocking sometimes so i really
set up these six
pillars as sort of behavior
sort of guard rails this is what we do
we don't criticize
and it's sort of a contract we like
mentally sign i read them over every day
this is what we're doing we're not going
to criticize
we're not going to find fault we're not
going to be resentful right
and we're going to find the good in
others we're going to let them know it
the next one was quick to apologize if
you feel like you hurt someone's feeling
if you're a little obtuse and
you you apologize first you say hey i'm
sorry i don't know if that offended you
but
please forgive me if it did a big game
changer and another one is we keep a
tally
of how we of how we are blessed
we keep a a a list of how fortunate we
are
to practice basically what's that a
gratitude practice a gratitude practice
and sometimes people don't have a
gratitude gratitude practice they have a
this is unfair practice this is why or
entitlement practice and the problem
with that
is it's it's simple math entitlement
makes you sad
gratitude makes you happy
if you feel like the world owes you
everything you're always going to be
miserable there's
never enough the world can owe you right
you know this
this uh architecture is not that
different
from 12-step and i know you've got this
like bhakti
12-step recovery program i want to spend
a little bit time talking about this
because
you know there's a lot of similarities
like you know
do a personal inventory hold yourself
accountable like take the next right
action you know make your
amends practice gratitude you know all
of these things are
endemic to recovery and are applicable
to humanity at large this is not like
just something that you know alcoholics
and drug addicts need to
figure out a way to master because truth
is for everyone and no one owns it and
no one's got a monopoly on it
yeah and uh there's people uh bill
wilson
they're like inspired they're somehow
inspired they've got the receiver on
just like right now there's like radio
waves in this room but we don't have our
receivers on we can't pick up the
the ham radio receivers or the channels
from france or the channels from the
country western station
but when you have that receiver you can
start picking up up all when you start
to
fine-tune your radar into spiritual
truth
not for your ego if you tune in with
your ego and spiritual truth you'll find
your little group
that hates that finds others but you
won't find commonality and connection
it'll be just another way for your ego
to live out
in the name of i'm better than and we
find that in any type of
i mean come on i'm like i said i'm a
cult aficionado
i found it when i was a raw foodist i
found a local
farmer growing straight edge krishna you
can always find
people who are into things you find in
politics
you definitely find it in religion that
if i'm doing something for myself
betterment
i shouldn't become more hateful if i'm
becoming more hateful
i think i'm doing something wrong
[Music]
you